you
all right we're ready to roll 62 was the
magic number and this guy got it let's
roll this is the first time we're
playing this name does not ring a bell
let's try this let's see how black
reacts push or support or takes and a
few options
all right so black is saying I want to
make sure I maintain upon d5 a foothold
in the center foothold with a foot
soldier on d5 all right so Queens gambit
declined hmm Bishop before Bishop e7 c6
are some options
all right c6 it is Bishop g5 goes down a
pretty theoretical line that I'm not
comfortable with and so and so what well
let me do this yeah I could play e3 I
could have captured and then played my
Bishop out if I played Bishop out right
away there is takes and then black is
gonna hang onto upon this Queen seems
like she's maybe going to be a bit
misplaced being on the C file I mean I'm
envisioning eventually a temple gaining
move with rook here even if this pawn
doesn't eventually recapture on d5 just
some indirect threat of a knight here or
capturing on d5 might force black to go
elsewhere with the Queen if Queen b6 I'd
I really wouldn't be capturing because
it helps out the rook but I would be
considering c5 so let's get in III my
bishop wants to get out
so I have no issue with my bad bishop
he's outside the pawn chain now where do
I go do I move my bishop remove my rook
to c1 I really don't think I should
capture I don't see how that helps me
Wow
well hang on why not capture and then
move my bishop now that this Knight is
blocking the bishop from coming out of
this classical diagonal maybe I should
just take and then play my Bishop to d3
mmm I'm gonna go here I can't make a
decision yet with my lights Corbett well
I mean I can but I just don't know I'm
not sure where he belongs
Vermont c1 let's see if black flinches
now one may be slightly a slight
downside to having the rook on c1 is if
the Queen plays to b6 and if I play c5
after takes takes my rook is gonna have
to come back over on a1 but I don't know
you can't have it all I guess so cannon
moves for black probably just castle all
right Castle it is and so they're not
really reacting I really think I should
yeah let me take now and then I'm my
bishop I don't I don't want to move my
bishop and then have black take and then
there will be this type of pawn break so
this is pretty much the only recapture
otherwise black is gonna get in some
deep trouble although like if you take
like this I can't move my knight just
yet because he's unprotected but okay
let's go here of these two squares if
there's no worry of some pin against the
knight why not go here it's kind of how
I quickly view it let's have a more
aggressive so watch over efore this is a
pivot point for black
you can also maybe just see it as watch
over a square that there could
potentially be a black minor piece
hopping too these are the two support
points for blacks minor pieces
alright so questions from - my bishop I
could go here I will go there it's with
the tempo it's the Queen Bishop d6 I
think you have issued d6 I think even
though it would be a trade of my bad
Bishop for blacks good Bishop it's he's
a very he's a very very good piece I
think it's a the right way to go I I
wouldn't have Knight b5 that's that's
not working if if Bishop d6 was played
when I'm castled then this is really it
would be a bad move but Bishop d6 Knight
b5 could be met with Queen a5 and my
knight would have to return so that's
not really working so my initial idea
was to not take the bishop and instead
back up I'm gonna do that and maybe
black will capture my Bishop b4 I Castle
I think it's a I think it's better for
black to actually keep the tension and
make a more useful move such as rook to
e8 they're down a lot of time here one
minute 20 so it's usually better to hold
off on that capture until I Castle and I
don't think I could I don't know what
other useful move I can be making in
this position so I'm just gonna go with
it so now if there's this capture at
least I don't have some play on the
h-file and this is this isn't really
weakness I see it more as an asset
capturing like this and that I have a
flight square although there are some
lines where you have to be cautious if
the Queen and Knight somehow get over to
this section of the board Kings side if
you can envision a knight on g4 Queen on
h5
with always some threat of the h2 square
of course I had to find a variation that
would lead to me saying h2 right so
Bishop takes or a knight move to get the
bishop out I was thinking more Knight f8
if the knight was going to move now this
is actually just losing because of that
that was the threat since I castled
out of this Queens gambit declined this
Queen on c8 is definitely misplaced she
probably shouldn't have moved as early
as she did so I'm just gonna take with
the knight could have taken with the
bishop but I'm just gonna take I'm
hitting the rope I want it this is going
to no welcome more exchanges so and it
really doesn't matter at this point it's
down on time in position so I'm gonna
try to kick the night around good post
up here that Knights gone less than 20
95 really anything at this point
Bishop here would have been good too for
a skewer no time you know position that
at this point
all right good game let's go back
actually you know what I want to do I
want to go back in a different way I
want to bring up this game so that it's
a bigger board I don't know why I've
always didn't do this
instead of staring at a very small board
could view it just like this so this is
the game we just played and again my
decisions here Bishop g5 but then D
takes see I'm not really a big fan of
that so Bishop out I could take Queen b3
III I like Queen b3 I want to still
follow through and have him outside of
my eventual pawn chain so this is just
misplaced the Queen really doesn't know
its role
what's an improvement is to focus on the
e5 square and you do that with the two
minor pieces that you have yet to
develop so your Bishop your King Bishop
your queen Knight Queen night on d7 your
Bishop on d6 and it's gonna it's gonna
be a better setup Bishop d6 97 Castle
rook e8 like you played in the game
really the only issue I'm having what
your development is your queen coming to
c7 and it turned out to be tactically
vulnerable as we saw with tonight b5
after I was castled what you could look
forward to at that point is if I'm
keeping this tension for too long you
could consider taking and then following
up with a pawn break of be 5 that would
be the idea if I'm taking like I did in
the game at this point right here I took
and then developed well I would maybe
even consider rook to e8 immediately
Bishop d6
although i mean age six isn't so bad but
definitely right here it's quite timely
you need to do something in fact I was I
was even wrong at this point right here
when I was saying if I was if there's
gonna be a night move plate I would be
going to f8 but this this is a main
threat right now as soon as I cancel so
you should take as soon as my I wouldn't
have some play on the H file take on g3
and as a follow-up night f8 and then
your Bishop is free to go out and it's
still a game but she's again it's just
coming out to the Queen being on a
vulnerable post on the c7 square okay
you